foreign
[Music]
McNamara I teach at the University of
Saint Thomas in Minnesota and I tweet at
Amelia MN I just tweeted a link to these
slides in case you want to follow along
so I'm really interested in our syntax
and also teaching statistics if you are
someone who teaches statistics you know
that we are always trying to have
students working with multivariate data
so in this example looking at the
relationship between flipper length and
Bill length of penguins between
different species to see if that
relationship is the same
um and I chose this sort of contrived
example to show you why Educators
believe that we should not be teaching
base R syntax and that is because it can
get really complicated really verbose
it's easy to make mistakes if you look
at those Graphics they don't even have
the same consistent axes so most
Educators agree we should either use the
formula syntax like from the Mosaic
package or the Tidy verse syntax and
both of those are going to create
beautiful ggplot2 graphics with those
consistent axes
but we have lots of opinions about which
of these we should use and not a lot of
data
so I did a semester-long head-to-head
comparison of the formula and tidy verse
syntaxes
why did I do this to myself I basically
doubled my work right I had to create
the materials in both syntaxes I tried
to make them as consistent as possible
in our markdown documents that had the
same text the only thing that was
different was the r syntax and the
reason for this is because I wanted to
get us some data and I also really
believe that constraints breed
creativity so if you put those
constraints on yourself it's going to
make you more creative
so here are my results
um some things are really easy
regardless of syntax our markdown or
quarto works so well inference works
well in intro staff whether you're using
the Mosaic package for inference or the
infer package in the Tidy verse
um but different things can be hard so
in the formula syntax dealing with and
explaining how we deal with missing data
that's pretty challenging there's
options there's n a DOT RM equal true
there's use equal complete Ops that was
tough in the Tidy verse dealing with and
explaining the relationship between two
categorical variables was a challenge so
we're used to seeing two categorical
variables explained in a two-way table
that's not a tidy data structure and
it's harder for me and for students to
conceptualize of the relationship when
it's in that tidy format and that can
have implications when you do things
like chi-square tests and proportion
tests
um the other thing that I was really
interested in is how much our code you
really needed in an intro stack course
and it turns out not that much so in the
formula section I exposed students to 37
functions in the Tidy verse section they
saw 50 functions those are a little bit
different in terms of numbers but both
of them over the course of 15 weeks
totally reasonable a big criticism of
the Tidy verse in teaching is oh there's
so many tidy verse functions how would
students ever learn them all well
they're not going to learn them you're
just going to show them the 50 that they
need and if you look at the top five in
each of these sections I think you'll
kind of see some of the differences here
as well so in the tideiverse section I
use the summarize function a lot every
time we did summary statistics I used
the ggplot function a lot every time I
built a graphic versus in the formula
section in the top five I have the GF
histogram that's apparently the graphic
that I made the most and I have the mean
function so a specific summary statistic
and you'd see some of those things kind
of coming up in the Tidy verse section
if I went further down the list
the other thing I found is there was a
difference in the amount of time
students were spending Computing on
rstudio cloud students in the tidyaver
section it looks like they spent more
time Computing why is this I have no
idea I probably should have collected
some data done some interviews asked
them is it because you're on there
you're like oh it's so fun I want to
keep looking I want to play around or is
it because it's really tough and you're
banging your head against the wall and
you're frustrated I don't know and
that's a great Avenue for future
investigations
um if you want to try something like
this yourself if you want to know how
many R functions do I show my students
use the r function get parse data and if
you want to know how much time each
individual student is spending on
rstudio cloud you can dig into your
browser's developer tools to kind of
sneak that data out
if you want to know more about how I did
this and what I found out I've got a
pre-print on the archive and if you want
my materials like my R marked on
documents you want to see how I got that
data for all my functions and how I
analyze the data for my paper you want
to read the paper all of that is
available I'm happy to take questions on
Discord and thanks so much
[Music]